- [Narrator] Where can
you see the Eiffel Tower,
Mont Saint Michel, and the Arc De Triomphe
all within a few steps of each other?
France, of course.
Well, Miniature France.
Located two hours outside of Paris,
Miniature France is a theme park
made in the image of real France,
but at 1/30 of the original size.
The park is 12 acres in size
and features 117 different monuments.
Miniature France was built by
a team of 50 model makers
and landscape architects,
ensuring that each model
is an exact replica
of its larger counterpart.
To make this hybrid city come to life,
there are animated
trains, cars, and planes
that move around the region.
And while you might not have time to see
all the real France has
to offer in one day,
you can make your way around
this park in one afternoon,
although your photos
might not be to scale.